hmm so NASA finds that water exists on
Mars the exact same week and the Martian
comes out a movie mind you that features
NASA very prominently coincidence I
think not but hey that's just a theory
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where today's episode promises to be
crappier than usual but that's got
nothing to do with the relative lameness
of the puns were using today it's
because we're talking about the Martian
and no that's no judgement on the movie
it's just full of poop poop science poop
signs that we're gonna pick through to
find the truth then flush and wash our
hands since that's the sanitary way to
go so what are all these rectal
ramblings about well the film is all
about an astronaut named Mark Watney
played by Matt Damon who gets severely
injured during a massive dust storm on
Mars his team believes him to be dead
and to save themselves evacuate the
planet escaping the storm and returning
to Earth as you do fun fact this is one
of the most scientifically inaccurate
parts of the movie you see the Martian
atmosphere is only about 1% the
thickness of Earth's meaning that it's
winds would pack much less of a punch
the worst the absolute worst storms on
Mars the type that only occur once every
five years or so wouldn't be enough to
register as a category one hurricane
that might be enough to knock you over
if I don't know you're not paying
attention but it surely isn't enough to
tip Rockets over or rip satellite dishes
off of buildings and impale them into
unsuspecting Matt Damon's but hey it's
just a setup a movie set up we'll let it
slide anyway the not so shocking twist
to these first five minutes since the
movie just started and Matt Damon's
faces all you see in the movies
Marketing does that surprise surprise
he's not dead
bum-bum-bum which means Watney is
stranded alone on the Red Planet and
must figure out how to survive until
NASA can figure out a way to bring him
home and will that might be easy in your
Star Trek Firefly or Battlestar
universes this is hard sci-fi which it
here is pretty true to life meaning of
the trip is gonna take a lot of time so
how can Watney last for over a year on a
planet without air or food well let me
tell you on the other side of the
spoiler warning now I won't be ruining
the ending of the film or really
anything major but we'll be talking
about several of the more sciency story
points if you don't want that sort of
thing spoiled pause this video and go
watch the movie or better yet read the
book or better better yet listen to the
audiobook man probably good a plan that
better anyway Watney isn't just any
astronaut I'm a botanist which means he
has the power over land at his side it's
convenient right outside of rationing
out the remaining food from the rest of
the crew he figures out a way to get the
nutrients and water necessary to grow
plants in the Martian soil and not just
any plant potatoes and this is what I
want to focus on today the science
around growing and living off of
potatoes on Mars because seriously there
is no way this can work in real life
right I mean I was sitting there in the
theater watching these scenes and
thinking to myself oh man I can't wait
to rip into these with some real facts
all right here's my chance let's break
it down first things first
living off of nothing but spuds and a
small ration for over 400 days it seemed
absurd but believe it or not you can
survive off of nothing but potatoes Sam
Gamgee once pointed out that the potato
is a very versatile food you can boil em
mash them and even stick them in a stew
but even he would be surprised to find
that it goes way beyond that
potatoes are actually pretty high in
almost everything that human body needs
to survive save for vitamins A b12 and
Eve as well as calcium in fact a man
named Chris Voigt executive director of
the Washington State potato Commission
because potatoes have rights to damage
we do 60 days of eating nothing but
potatoes just to prove that it was
possible and oh yeah it was possible but
as his blog entries show you're not
gonna enjoy yourself
you should freed these things by day
three it's obvious he's already starting
to kick himself quote I finished day
three last night I have to admit it has
finally sunk in that I'll be eating just
potatoes for 57 more days oh yeah you
will buddy and the deeper and deeper you
go the more desperate it becomes here's
the rub though he was eating 20 potatoes
a day some mornings for breakfast he was
eating between two and four pounds of
hash browns
Watney had his leanest is doing a single
potato a day it doesn't seem like enough
right and honestly it isn't a medium
potato is giving your body about a
hundred and sixty-three calories when a
man like Watney needs a
mm but it's not as bad as it might seem
remember Watney is on Mars where the
gravity is one-third of what it is on
earth so while he's still doing a ton of
work each day in his efforts to survive
he's having to spend much less energy to
do that work add to that the small
amount of rations he's allowed to eat
and the fact that his fellow teammates
left behind pills most likely including
some vitamin supplements and it's not
hard to believe that he could survive on
this diets
long story short can a man live on bread
alone yeah he can for about six months
then he dies of scurvy can a man live on
potatoes alone surprisingly yes better
than bread as long as you give him the
occasional Flintstones chewable he's
good to go
so all right round one goes to the
Martian it's hit my cap to you movie
we're not done yet
what about actually growing the potatoes
in Martian soil well the first issue
would be Mars as distance from the Sun
the planet is one and a half times
further from the Sun than Earth and get
60% of the light so plants would grow
much slower as a result but the bigger
issue here would be the nutritional
deficiencies in the soil unlike earth
where bacteria fixes nitrogen from the
atmosphere making the soil much more
conducive to plant life Mars doesn't
have that benefit but lo and behold the
uncontested best botanist on Mars has a
solution for that problem to help
fertilize the soil he gets from the
surface of Mars Matt Damon uses his own
feces as manure
he even goes out to the back of the
structure he's staying in and reclaims
all of the feces his crewmates left
before they evacuated evacuated probably
more accurate to say after they
evacuated before they evacuated but okay
seeing this I was skeptical this is
really such a good idea why don't we use
our bum brownies as manure here on earth
well surprise surprise we do now tell me
are you grossed out to know that someone
else's excrement has been all up in that
carrot you currently have stuck in your
mouth by the way good on you for being
healthy and that loyal theorists is why
you wash your food in fact using human
feces like this started thousands of
years ago and was called night soil
because the feces was collected at night
from cesspools and outhouses to be used
during the day as fertilizer nowadays it
has the much more scientific and
hygienic name biosolids
in
act as of 2013 55% of us sewage solids
aka your butt butter was turned into
fertilizer and farmers want more these
people are making money off of your poop
and you're not seeing a cent of that I
mean at least YouTube gives us a 55/45
split when they sell the crap that we
produce alright that said in all
seriousness Matt Damon would have faced
yet another problem with this see
biosolids are heavily treated human
feces the raw stuff is rarely used as
manure because every human carries
pathogens things that make you sick
think viruses bacteria parasites Adam
Sandler films humans are immune to their
own pathogens but the pathogens of
others can be very dangerous and this
isn't just a case of being careful while
handling someone else's poop if
pathogens exist in the soil that a plant
is growing in they can be transferred
into the plants so using as crewmates
excrement would have been disastrous for
Matt Damon had space not once again save
the day Watney is on Mars meaning that
the feces left behind by his crewmates
was freeze-dried and then exposed to the
near vacuum and sub-freezing
temperatures of Mars's atmosphere as a
result the pathogens would have been
killed and Watney would be just fine in
the words of Jeff Goldblum life signs
away so in this episode I'm batting oh
four to the science around our turn
tubers are poop potatoes stacks up
almost 100 percents notice though that I
said almost and that's because there's
still one fatal flaw here a flaw that I
can't really blame the author of the
book for not addressing since this fact
was discovered after he had already
written the story you see loyal
theorists in May of 2008 the Phoenix
Mars Lander performed the very first
ever wet chemical analysis of the dirt
on the surface of Mars and found that
roughly 0.6 percent of Martian soil is
made up of perchlorate don't worry
you're not supposed to know what that is
in fact NASA when they found it even had
to look it up perchlorates are basically
salts that are capable of disrupting the
body's metabolic systems they interfere
with our ability to absorb iodine
messing with the production of thyroid
hormone
and potentially throwing off mood
appetite temperature sleep and more
messing with hormones never a good thing
I mean perchlorates are used in some
rocket propellants so you know maybe not
the healthiest thing for humans to be
consuming in large quantities in fact
it's also the reason we recently found
liquid water in the sub-zero
temperatures of the Martian surface like
we mentioned at the top of the episode
you know how salt water requires colder
temperatures to freeze well the same
principle holds here perchlorates are
the salt acting as a sort of antifreeze
and lowering the freezing point of water
hence liquid water on Mars but this is
why it matters in the context of the
Martian long term exposure can result in
much higher chances of developing
thyroid cancer and though 0.6% might not
seem like a lot it's well above Earth
levels and far beyond fda-regulated
amounts which means I win right I found
my scientific loophole Matt Damon would
have died wouldn't he or at the very
least would have been at risk for some
long-term health defects right well to
determine that we need to first figure
out how much Martian dirt mark would be
inhaling and see if he reaches toxic
levels according to the Environmental
Protection Agency a typical human
between the ages of 1 and 20 consumes a
hundred milligrams of dirt a day for
Watney on Mars with 0.6 percent of that
being perchlorate that's point 6
milligrams of perchlorate a day and
since the potatoes are planted in the
stuff they'll absorb a bit from there
too so he'll consume say rounding this
out to aggressively one milligram of
perchlorate per day multiply that by the
500 or so days he's consuming the stuff
and honestly he's still in the clear
according to the agency for toxic
substances and disease registry tests
were done on healthy volunteers who took
35 milligrams of perchlorate every day
for 14 days and 3 milligrams a day for
six months both groups absolutely fine
and by our calculations worst case
scenario Watney would be consuming
one-third of that amount for three times
the amount of time so presumably he
would be okay and that extrapolation of
the data is supported by longitudinal
research long-term studies looking at
similar levels of exposure over the
course of year
showed similar results no effect in
other words it would take a lot more of
the stuff over a much longer time to
start affecting the thyroid and if all
else fails here's the kicker even if
these were immediately toxic levels of
perchlorate there would be a really easy
solution to it wash the dirt seriously
simple as that wash the dirt soak the
soil in some water let the perchlorate
dissolve pour the water out and then
boil it to reclaim the water remember
it's just salt watney's biggest threat
would just need a bath
in conclusion try as I might to science
the doubt of these scenes to find a
reason why this absurd premise of
planting potatoes and Mars would
obviously kill mark Watney off the
Martian did its homework from every
angle the potatoes the fecal fertilizer
even the deadly salt all explained away
these farming scenes are pretty darn
airtight which is good since swanee is
out there in the near vacuum of space
and you know what I'm ok losing this one
it's refreshing to see a piece of
science fiction pay attention to the
real-world science so good a new Martian
or the Martian your science gets the
theorists stamp of approval I guess you
could say that the Martians crap science
isn't crap science but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut